Poland's defense minister says the
country's border with Belarus is in
danger he says Minsk backed by Moscow as
encouraging illegal Crossings to
destabilize Poland Russia's Wagner group
set up base in Belarus last month near
the Polish border Warsaw responded by
deploying troops with plans to send up
to ten thousand to the area well Osama
bin Javed joins us now from Bob rodnicki
in Poland and somehow is the Polish
government explaining why it needs such
a large number of troops along the
border
what you've heard from the Polish
defense minister today for the first
time actually coming out to meet his
troops some of them who are going to be
positioned along the Belarus Poland
border saying that it is not just the
threat of migration that he faces but
also we've been hearing from politicians
saying that there these migrants could
be Guys these could be Wagner
mercenaries guys there's migrants that
would cross into Poland vis-a-vis cross
into NATO and cause disruptions
obviously that is a claim which has not
found any evidence on the ground yet
rights workers and people who are
working on the border say that this is
another Claim by this right-wing
government which has been going against
migrations it is one of their rallying
cries and it is because this is just a
few weeks away from elections they want
to Rally their voter base as well so it
is interesting to see the defense
minister coming out along with his
generals making statements such as there
is going to be if there is any
provocation that happens on the border
if there are any incursions that happen
on the border there's going to be an
immediate response saying it is not
going to take weeks or days but it will
be immediate response to any provocation
so again this is happening in the
backdrop of uh not just a rising number
of people who've attempted to cross the
border but also at least two aircrafts
from the Belarusian side who've crossed
into polish territory according to
polish officials denied by Belarus as
well but again a direct consequence of
the ongoing war in Ukraine where you
find Poland positioning itself as the
defender of NATO's border against Russia
and its allies
know some of what will the soldiers
actually be doing at the border because
as we understand it there is already
offense with barbed wires motion sensors
and and cameras
foreign
we were there on the board of fence a
couple of times in various locations and
where you can see the barbed wire five
meter high fence 187 kilometers long but
there are still patches between these
two countries where defense is not there
there are rivers there there is terrain
where the fence cannot be erected and
even the fence in itself has not been
able to stem the flow of people crossing
into Europe so these soldiers
essentially are going to be doing
patrols both via drones as well as
manned boots on the ground patrols on
land as well as carrying out activities
on the border to make sure that they
catch those people who entered Poland
illegally and then hand them over to the
Border guards so their Abbott has been
described as some as a force which is
allowed to use Force if it needs to but
boy and large they're going to be
supplementing the duties of the Border
guard there we've been speaking to these
soldiers some of them said that they've
been uh there for 700 days demanding
these borders as long as there's been a
crisis in Ukraine and they say that
they've they've faced uh people who've
had military training before they've
faced people who were trying to
illegally enter Poland but they are not
allowed to detain them they're not
allowed to interrogate them they're
supposed to hand them over to the board
of guard which then most of the time
pushes them back into the territory
where they came from and rights
activists have been telling us that it
is an indiscriminate pushing back where
miners including children and people who
need medical attention have also been
turned back something which according to
activists on the ground is against the
conventions that European union and its
members have signed on okay thank you so
much Osama that is Osama Bin Javed initi
in Poland